the use of illegal fireworks appears to
be skyrocketing in America and it's not
clear why complaints are soaring to
during a time when many people are
already on edge due to the pandemic of
course following he is in New York where
the barrage is literally keeping people
up at night mola how bad is it well
Anthony people have been reporting this
problem really from coast to coast here
in Brooklyn folks say that they've been
seeing and hearing these illegal
fireworks go off almost every single
night for weeks firework retailers say
they have seen their sales skyrocket and
that is causing some dangerous
situations really across the country
they're in Los Angeles Baltimore in New
York City
powerful displays of illegal fireworks
disrupting neighborhoods across the
country the morning you wake in a you
know during an explosion my baby takes
longer naps during the day because he
does not get enough sleep during the
night and he wakes up crying he used to
sleep in the spoon some of them are
firecrackers some of them sound like
bombs
communities nationwide have seen
increases in complaints in New York City
911 calls about illegal fireworks shot
up more than 1200 percent from last year
in Boston they rose by nearly sixty five
hundred percent and in Pasadena
California there was a roughly four
hundred sixty percent increase it's just
skyrocketed this year that's Pasadena
police sergeant Keith Gomez who's part
of the city's newly created firework
detail we don't want people to
unnecessarily burn down their home burn
down their neighbor's home it's unclear
what's behind the recent spike in
dangerous displays but Maureen Vogel
with the National Safety Council told us
it could pose major risks to the people
who are around them here in New York
City those concerns prompted Mayor Bill
DeBlasio to launch a taskforce targeting
illegal fireworks there'll be all sorts
of actions taken under cover by sting
operations finding where the supply is
and cutting it off at the knees anything
like this Brooklyn Borough President
Eric Adams told us the crackdown will be
a test of not just enforcement but
community engagement
he's urging residents to think twice
before calling 9-1-1
how do you find the right balance not to
be heavy-handed as we deal with a
nuisance a non-violent infraction how do
you do it I think it's a combination of
a light touch from police in but a real
interaction with everyday citizens and
everyday
organizations now Adams there
acknowledge that those sounds that
people hear the fireworks going off can
be more than just a nuisance you know
for some people who may not know what
the sounds are they could think that
they're gunshots going off or it might
trigger PTSD and other people so he says
he's been walking the streets of
Brooklyn at night trying to find the
people who are launching them to try to
explain the dangers to them
Anthony mola thank you I Gayle I've only
heard I've heard one or two and they are
very startling but I think complaints
all over the place about them no I don't
hear them on the Upper West Side but I
do hear that it's a serious problem when
you think what it can trigger in people
it's not a good thing so be careful
right